it's a very difficult time at the moment
recently you commented that there needed
to be greater unity within the EU you
were worried about what some countries
were doing what was it that caused you
concern Naruto first of all I would like
to greet Boris Johnson who's a friend
and I really from my heart wish him all
the best and a quick recovery we need a
common response we are facing a pandemic
that is due to global phenomenon and the
response cannot come from single
countries the European Union believes
that we should act act together strongly
in order to defend our citizens and
overcome this health emergency and also
to rebuild our continent afterwards our
economies are stalling our industries
are closed and we should revitalize our
economy afterwards we must protect our
citizens and guarantee the security and
the stability of our social model you do
acknowledge that initially at least
there was perhaps a failure of of
leadership a failure of direction from
the EU institutions she yes I had said
that and I can repeat it in the
beginning it looks like every EU country
was acting on its own closure of the
internal markets closure of borders no
more free circulation but that was just
a phase and now we're over it
some measures were taken to better
defend our external borders and now free
circulation of goods especially can be
ensured especially goods that are needed
in this health crisis so these are some
very important measures our countries
must spend wherever you need it but we
must give a guarantee that this
spandy tur will not create too big a
burden too big a deficit on our national
budgets there is the immediate challenge
obviously at the moment perhaps the
biggest challenge it afterwards is going
to be the economic recovery that you
talked of should there be a sharing of
responsibility across the year European
Union for that it is all the talk of
Euro bonds sharing the debt some
countries not happy with that idea at
all
what do you think the responsibility
should be your grade or I believe that
we should use all the tools available to
us they probably will not be enough
we'll have to invent to create new tools
but at the same time I believe the
discussion on the influenced by a memory
the memory of the 2008 economic crisis
when we're talking about Korona bonds
we're talking about emergency tools
tools for Reconstruction and we're not
talking about solving the debt problems
of some states that's the fear that some
countries have expressed but I'm sure
that sufficient reassurances will be
given about this do not need to solve
the historical debt problem that some
countries have but we need to keep the
possibility to our citizens today to
face this difficult time while this is
all been going on obviously many other
issues have had to be put to the side
not least brexit the negotiations have
been stalled is it now inevitable that
there will have to be an extension to
the transition period questura BK that
you should ask this to the UK
authorities as everybody knows TP has
recently proposed
recorded nineteen emergency of the 31st
of December should have been put off so
postponed at least until March since
negotiation are stalled as you said we
missed some possibilities to discuss
several meetings have been canceled the
timetable will have to be revised
we are fully available to postpone the
date so instead of the 31st of December
think about March 2000 or 2001 but it's
UK authorities that will have to decide
and we still don't know which way they
they are headed and if the UK it
continues to insist that it has to be
the 31st of December what is the risk
look what could happen in terms of a
comprehensive deal your risky idea
negotiation will not progress we might
get to a situation where we have no
rules because we had to agree these
rules we might not have an agreement no
free trade agreement discussions are
have not advanced enough on this so it
would be able to reach an agreement
satisfactory to all the parties that's
our point of view we have to decide you
might end up with no deal yes peril you
know I hope no show me record ok
parlamento british parliament has voted
against I know you do
you